thank you
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
hmm
[Music]
I have with me David Pac-Man he is a
progressive host
an executive producer of the nationally
syndicated radio and TV program The
David Hackman show and I wanted to talk
to David
here's everything
[Music]
[Music]
can you remind the audience when you
talk about being a beta male and being
an alpha male what are we talking about
here
there are males most men today yeah male
they think and act like a woman they're
emotional they are mentally off they
have no logic
[Music]
just like a woman
[Music]
now
[Music]
please
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we all need people
if there is anything that needs to be uh
satirized and remixed
it is Trump talking about massive dumps
and by the way extra points if you can
sample Trump saying massive dumps and me
talking about it in a song please do it
big massive dumps
dumps
[Music]
dumps
big massive dumps dumps
big massive dumps
multiple times that it was massive dumps
that led him to lose the election which
is just
dumps
[Music]
big massive dumps dumps
big massive dump in areas
people are flushing toilets 10 times 15
times as opposed to Once
dumps dumps dumps
what is going on here what is going what
is going on here
it's just beyond parody a massive ducks
cost of the election
what is going on here what is go what is
going on here
it's just beyond parody a massive dumps
past the election
what is going on here
dumps
[Music]
dumps
[Music]
dumps
dump big massive dumps
[Music]
wow welcome everybody it is a new stream
and I truly can't even believe that I am
here I'm going to tell you what's been
going on there's so much to catch up on
I have dozens of browser tabs open which
will hopefully not lag the stream
um but it's just amazing to be back it's
basically been
December 2nd
it's basically been 25 days since the
last real stream I had an abortive false
start stream at some point during my
travels and vacation but due to a
combination of an underpowered computer
as well as uh as well as what as well as
um
just a bad internet connection
that uh it didn't it didn't go very well
we ended up having to reschedule the
town hall for tomorrow and all these
different things so we're I'm we're
going to get caught up on everything
we're going to talk about the omnicron
the Omicron explosion
uh proposed or suggested vax
requirements for flying and so many
different things I don't even know where
to start I guess let me start with one
announcement which is see over there
where it's blacked out normally the
super chats from YouTube would be there
super chats are working but YouTube has
changed the back end of their streaming
platform where there used to be a
section called viewer activity and
that's where we would screen capture
super chats from
that tab is gone
so I I'm waiting for our our YouTube rep
um to tell me where else we can find
those uh super chats the super chats are
working I think if someone sends one
I'll be able to say for sure they're
just not automatically showing up on the
screen so we'll we'll get it figured out
we'll figure out how to get those back
on the screen we'll have to have some
kind of alternative
a system or something like that but
um yeah I just don't know super people
saying use a use a uh you
super chats are not part of the API as
best as I can tell in terms of like for
example
above me where it says twitch Subs 283
which by the way is a humiliating number
like please nobody go and tell Hassan
about that because it's humiliating
um that's that's using the Twitter API
so we don't that's not a screen capture
super chats as far as I know
guys Howard how are super chats going to
be twitch events
it's a YouTube thing how on Earth would
we get super chats from twitch
that doesn't make any sense
um please give me good suggestions guys
please it's a Super Chat is YouTube
there's no twitch event that gives me
super chats it's not it's not a twitch
feature
um anyway we're gonna look into that
okay we're gonna look into that
and yeah super chats work so Verena
Fraser just said let's try Andrew
D'Angelo just sent to Super Chat okay so
super chats working but just not on
screen please don't beat me up over it
we're gonna do everything we can
um okay let me get to the the just the
first news element because I want to
talk about it and then we have so much
to talk about I'm so glad you guys are
here it's gonna be I don't know how long
the stream will be it's going to be
pretty wide it'll be remarkably deep but
it may not be long
we are not on vacation this week uh I am
here last week we were graced with uh
faren cousins faren Destiny cousins IV
from Ring of Fire for four days of guest
hosting producer Pat Ford filled in for
me on Christmas Eve I believe that's
still I believe we're still allowed to
say Christmas Eve as Donald Trump would
say
um
yeah so uh but I it's all new shows new
shows this week okay
let's get into it uh fauci says domestic
travel vax rule should be considered
considered not very dictatorial to say I
don't know maybe consider something
seems quite measured in fact uh
President Joe Biden's medical advisor
said a domestic travel vaccination rule
should be considered
as the Omicron variant fuels record
caseloads in some states
we have the video
let's take a look at what he had to say
will you recommend to President Biden
there should be a requirement for
vaccination for domestic travel
you know I I'm not going to tell you
that for the simple reason is that I
don't want to be publicly telling what
I'm recommending to the president
because then the president doesn't do it
I don't want to make it look he's going
against it the president eminently
reasonable it takes all recommendations
all discussions and as a group we make a
decision about what's best to do there
are pros and cons to that I mean you've
got to ask yourself why it is you're
making that requirement if you're making
a requirement for vaccination for people
to get on planes who are coming into the
country that's understandable you don't
want to bring more cases into the
country but if you're talking about
requiring a vaccination to get on a
plane domestically that is just another
one of the requirements that I think is
reasonable to consider and I think
that's what you're talking about when
you heard me make a comment you know
there's requirements that you might want
to get if you want to get into college
or you want to go to a university or you
want to work in certain places when you
make vaccine Nation a requirement that's
another incentive to get more people
vaccinated if you want to do that with
domestic flights I think that's
something that seriously should be
considered yeah so you know uh eminently
reasonable I am so now I hope
everybody's relaxed for what I'm about
to say because I want you to listen to
what I'm saying not to what you think
I'm saying
I would be in favor of this completely
and I've said it for a long time and
with Omicron or the omnicron as Joe
Biden says I do not believe we are going
to vaccinate our way out of omnicron
uh uh because it is so contagious it is
at the point where it is we're being
told as contagious as the cold
as a cold and so what the vaccines will
do is reduce hospitalization and death
and hopefully to some degree
transmission two doses apparently thirty
percent effective at preventing
asymptomatic infection a symptomatic
infection rather three doses 70 percent
um but this thing is spreading like
wildfire look at some of these data or
Dater as some might say this is in the
United States look at that 268
000 cases that we knew about on December
23rd
probably just as many people are not
getting tested who have it because if
for so many people this new variant is
so mild probably 500 000 cases on
December 23rd at minimum uh globally
we are seeing about a million a day as
you can see here we had these very big
numbers here 989
000 and again there's so many areas
where testing is not capturing anywhere
near all the cases so the reason we need
the vaccines is because they are
extremely effective at keeping people
out of the hospital and preventing
people from dying you know who
recognized this the other day
uh Donald Trump who told Candice blowins
these vaccines
are making it so that if you get it you
don't die and he was completely correct
about that completely correct and um
here is an emergency room physician
talking a little bit about this back and
folks that are vaccinated
vaccinated what
will break down from your estimation of
what you've been seeing
I would say the vast majority of people
coming into the ICU are those that are
unvaccinated there are a very few
percent of people that are being
admitted to the ICU that have been fully
vaccinated but usually those people are
high-risk people that have critical
illness anyways uh and not healthy
people
um that are fully vaccinated yeah
for folks that are unvaccinated are they
expressing any regret and not getting
vaccinated before getting sick
um there has been some regrets uh some
people stick to their beliefs about not
getting vaccinated but they're I have
been expressed by patients that they did
wish they would have gotten vaccinated
when they become severely ill okay and
then we have a very interesting thread
here from Dr Craig Spencer not only MD
but also mph I think it's important to
mention Dr Craig Spencer
a medical doctor right Dr Jordan B
Peterson not a medical doctor still
called doctor by many people not a
medical doctor okay let's this is a very
instructive thread
um I've seen a lot of covet in the ER
recently with so many people getting
infected recently some folks May wonder
what's the point of getting vaccinated
at all and is there really any value to
a booster dose if I've had two freiser
moderna or shot of jnj my observations
every patient I've seen with covid
that's had a third booster dose has had
mild symptoms by mild I mean mostly sore
throat lots of sore throat fatigue
muscle pain no difficulty breathing no
shortness of breath all a little
uncomfortable but fine
most patients I've seen that had two
doses still had mild symptoms but more
than those who received a third more
fatigue more fever more coughing a
little more miserable overall but no
shortness of breath or difficulty
breathing mostly fine
most patients I've seen that had one jnj
and had covid were worse felt horrible
fever for a few days or more weak tired
shortness of breath and cough but no one
needing hospitalization not one needing
oxygen not great but not
life-threatening
and almost every single patient I've
taken care of that needed to be admitted
has been unvaccinated everyone with
profound shortness of breath everyone
whose oxygen dropped when they walked
everyone needing oxygen to breathe
regularly the point is you're going to
hear about a lot of people getting
coveted in the coming days and weeks
those that have been vaccinated and got
a booster will mostly fare well with
minimal symptoms those getting two doses
might have a few more symptoms but
should still do well
those who got a single jmj jnj may have
more but have more protection than
unvaccinated
but the burden falls on the unvaccinated
those who haven't gotten a single dose
they're the most likely to need oxygen
they're the most likely to have
complications they're the most likely to
get admitted and the most likely to stay
in the hospital for days or longer with
severe covet just observations from my
recent shifts in the ER no matter your
political affiliation or thoughts on
masks or where you live as an ER doctor
you trust with your life if you rolled
into my emergency room at 3am I promise
you you'd rather face the oncoming
Omicron wave vaccinated please be safe
um clip it please folks clip it exactly
so so I actually
uh I am I faced off against Omicron last
week
and I'm going to tell you the story in a
few days I want the story I want the
book to be written in full before I
publish it
okay I faced off with the omnicron in
the last week and I'm going to tell
everybody about it now faced off
I'm using that language for a very
specific reason
okay so everybody everybody calm down
everybody relax uh we're going to be
looking at all of it very very strongly
so that's the fauci stuff we took care
of that we saw what he had to say
we saw this we saw this okay very very
good
um all right
why what's going on this week what
exactly is going on this week I'm going
to be very upfront with everybody we
have had a disastrous
puppies that's like seven syllables
um December and partially because of uh
technical elements that didn't go right
and all these different things it's been
a very very rough December so I am here
to tell you
I am conceivably willing to stream every
day for the remainder of the Year up to
and here's the important part including
New Year's Eve
so a lot of people are going to do the
up to right but I'm doing up to and
including New Year's Eve every day that
we get a hundred website members and
twitch Subs I will commit to streaming
the next day
and we will do this all the way through
the 31st and we will do a New Year's Eve
stream if we get all the way there so
I'm going to thank every single person
who signs up because it's been so crazy
uh
oh boy tested positive not me I just got
a message from a friend who I almost had
dinner with last week but we were able
to wave it we were waived off at the
last second
uh
oh man not good
symptoms let's see what symptomatic
elements he has oh boy
all right we'll get back to him later
see what kind of symptoms he's dealing
with
um okay so uh and in addition I'm gonna
give you guys two other
um options uh for things that can be
done number one
if you get a full price yearly
membership on my website Obama
I will give you a free T-shirt If you
want okay full price yearly on the
website email info davidpackman.com
we'll get a free t-shirt out to you
second option use the coupon code obamna
and just take the discount Obama okay
and I want to say thank you to Evan
Haney who just signed up today and is
new member number one we're also gonna
get back over to Twitch thank yous let's
see how many we've got I want to say
thanks to
here we go Billy Carpenter sirwin Beth
small fuzzy Moss life is good weather
boxer physicist nasty questions Jewish
Nick Cannon liquid ice Jam lock flea
girl Lily MW Jen here Jen here with a
gift WX forecaster Astro lycos Samsung
David ketchup Bowflex man Matt jaccia
and mzara that's 23 23 plus one three
plus one is four nothing to carry and
then a two puts us at 24. okay if we get
to 100 today
I will commit to a stream tomorrow we do
have the town hall on the pack live
Channel tomorrow Paco internally we call
it pack live Pac-Man Live
um that's happening but I will commit to
an at least an hour stream on all
platforms including twitch before the
town hall if we get to 100 today
uh oh and snippy Snips gifting five
already rocketing us to 29. uh okay so
we got that I have 1100 voicemails to go
through with you guys but we're gonna go
through those a little bit later because
it's still early there let's move on to
some other things I have so many
different things that people have sent
me uh first of all we are seeing a
completely unremarkable and cyclical
price movement for the fruit known as
mango
nothing remarkable at all
uh there's been a lot of hay made about
mango prices up under the Biden regime
we got to bring my mangoes back down but
actually this is a mango chart price it
seems almost seasonal
almost seasonal and here's the latest as
this is where the mango elements came
from originally
mangoes
Amanda Trump calls
I love mangoes too nonsense okay now
that we are up under our Biden's regime
my bag of mangoes now calls
11.99 that seems like a pretty good deal
a bag of mangoes mango aren't mangoes
like three bucks each that's it I want
what to eight or 11 bucks that sounds
good and the American people belong
way robbery is what you're doing that's
right
my man goes back down that's right
bring him down right about that and the
Wisconsin crowd not identifying with the
mango material proportionately affected
don't raise the price of fruit don't you
want me to be healthy though okay so we
do have a remix
that was done which is just beautiful
mangoes my bags of mangoes
I love mangoes too
nonsense
now that we are up under our body's
regime
my bag of mangoes now costs
11.99
man I just love this song whoops oh my
God the American people alive
[Music]
[Music]
the Wisconsin crowd identified from the
mangoes
[Music]
don't want me to me
[Music]
as highway robbery is what you doing
[Music]
mangoes I would submit to you that
that's the hardest hitting mango related
music
I would argue the world over I it's hard
for me to imagine any harder hitting
mango song
I think anywhere
um it's I mean I just it's hard to
imagine it okay so that's number one and
then while we are on the topic of fruit
just to really close out the fruit Arc
of the show
um I am going to you know people were
talking I was looking for this Plum
recently that's like dark purple on the
inside and I have not been able to find
exactly which one it is
I have found the perfect citrus fruit
okay and I am about to disclose what it
is and I don't know if people want to
guess do people anybody want to guess
what citrus fruit I am about to
um
essentially Crown the best citrus fruit
globally Yuzu
lemon kiwi is kiwi Citrus grapefruit
persimmon pomelo
we're gonna get down to the oranges of
the investigation
uh
some of these I don't even know if
they're citrus fruit but not a single
person has said it
Bergamot what the hell a Meyer lemon man
nobody's got it people are also listing
non-citrus fruit but that that I don't
really care about that
I don't want any if if uh by the way
if in three days Ian vosh is talking
about this fruit or Destiny or Molina
have audio drops like they stole Obama
from me Obama if you hear about this
since no one's even guessing it if
anybody sees anything about this
particular citrus fruit on any other
stream and if if Ian varsh takes it
we're going to have a problem
uh maybe Tim Poole will steal it like my
thumbnails
um you know it came from this show
because nobody nobody nobody is
mentioning this for oh
there it is Danish joint and Samsung it
is the Satsuma Mandarin I am ready to
tell you this is the top citrus fruit
the world over two people got it correct
this is an extraordinary fruit
look at this
read let me tell you about this insane
fruit
Citrus unshu also known as the Satsuma
okay it's semi-seedless which I love
it's actually complete completely
seedless
easy peeling easy peeling this is the
this is the Greek key thing Citrus
species known as the miyagawa the unshu
a cold hearty Mandarin Satsuma I call it
I know it is the Satsuma
uh nart G that looks almost Dutch and
tangerine
uh it was named after unshu a famous
production area of Mandarin and origins
in China in the late Edo period look at
the history it's so rich in history it's
said to have originated in Japan or
China
due to multiple genetic studies we are
actually doing the morphology the theory
is that the maternal species was kishu
and the dad was kunenbo imagine your dad
is kunenbo that's how you end up like
this and it was created in the Satsuma
province in Japan
um okay what are the elements of it
characteristics its fruit is look at
this one of the sweetest Citrus
varieties love it
usually seedless
amazing it can't reproduce no need for
birth control
about the size of other mandarins no
doubt about it and this is the crucial
critical moment
satsumas are known for loose leathery
skin the fruit is easily peeled
there's a lot of these and what's great
is a lot of people think it's gone bad
because they pick it up and it's
completely soft to the touch and if you
picked up an a regular like a navel and
it was that soft you'd say it's Rancid
you'd say it's clearly gone bad it's
soft because of air between the Flesh
and the skin
and so people pick it up and they oh
this must not be good I swoop in and I
just steal them I mean I probably do it
I don't mean I steal I pay for them from
the store but I steal them out from
other people's carts because people say
this must be rancid it's not rancid this
is the best Citrus okay if Ian vosh
starts talking about it Tim pool
Melania croissant if any of them start
talking about Satsuma
you send them to me
okay you send them to me because this is
this is the absolute
I have never seen anything like this
I really have not I've been I've been
loading up on these is it good for
juicing I have no idea
yeah call me David paksuma exactly right
all right let me thank a few more people
before we move on from the fruits I want
to say thanks to Stephen register for
signing up on my website Brian hark is a
new member Christopher Bruno signed up
with the coupon code Obama Obama and
Heather Jones signing up with the coupon
code Obama
putting us at 33 also want to say thanks
to
everybody supporting via twitch uh that
includes Sling Blade epic Hatchet Napa
skip dog Lambert fuhrer diabolicus a
Danish joint big tasty Ryan VV spatman
Steve and Bobo fetra putting us at 43 my
promise to you today
is that if we get to a hundred I will
commit to a stream tomorrow and I am
willing to stream every day up to and
including New Year's Eve we've never
done a New Year's Eve stream before and
I will stream on New Year's Eve if we do
that we're 43 of the way there all right
so I appreciate everybody uh who is here
let me see what else we've got here
uh
uh okay no I think we're we're all good
there
oh and again two options for signing up
today if you pay full price for the year
I'll send you a free t-shirt but you
gotta ask me for it email info
davidpackman.com if you pay 60 bucks for
the year okay or to pay almost nothing
use the coupon code Obama Obama and
you'll get uh like 70 off or something
crazy like that all right so all very
very exciting next item I have for you
guys
um I don't know how many of you were
following uh how many of you follow me
on Twitter or Instagram but this was
very weird during my break
a profile it's like an AstroTurf profile
uh showed up on Twitter with my picture
and it's a very strange picture of me
very very strange picture of me
um someone supposedly named Bert
who is allegedly a husband a father and
a happy Amazon employee had the message
unions are good for some companies
but I don't want to have to Shell out
hundreds a month just for lawyers and
it's my picture now what's really
bonkers
let me see if the profile still exists
okay for a t
oh my God it's still there
I reported this to Twitter
for impersonation
I reported this to Twitter for copyright
because I own the copyright for this
picture as in saying a picture as it is
with one strand look at that strand of
hair going down
this is a copyright violation like this
I get hit with bogus copyright all the
time this is a legit copyright violation
and the profile I've reported it
and as far as I know many of you have
reported it
and it won't go away
oh my God and they're even look at this
oh look at this who is this David Pacman
I'm Bert
and they even tweeted about the fact
look at that I tweeted Twitter has
reviewed it and says it's fine
and then this person actually retweeted
that
so anyway
it's it's unbelievable oh my God this
person is getting followers
they didn't they just have like 12
followers and now they have 34.
that's crazy don't follow them
um so anyway that's completely insane
it's extremely creepy extremely
extremely creepy okay
um here's another interesting thing as a
as an obvious joke I tweeted the other
day we're no longer going to let
unvaccinated people leave comments on
our YouTube channel or even watch our
videos expecting major blowback this is
not only obviously a joke it's also
technically impossible like you'd have
to think to yourself wait
does YouTube know if I'm vaccinated
if the answer is no then how on Earth
Earth could we prevent you
from
commenting or watching and there were a
bunch of people who replied acting as if
I was serious let me see if I can find
him here
um
a couple people seem to think I was for
real
great idea now where was it
I I was like you've got to be kidding me
right
um
I get covered not good at all no this
isn't it
there were a couple people who seemed to
think it was for real
maybe not
maybe they were Mass flagged
I think if you could weed out the moral
superiority and the precarious logic and
omission of inconvenient truths you
might be on to something
uh how can you enforce this
we can't it's obviously a joke it's
hilarious watching people take this
seriously yeah
no it's crazy
unfollowed thank you and I am vaccinated
like that's clearly someone taking it
seriously
and they have to be told it's a joke
you can't be blocked from watching a
video
here's another one you're making a valid
point but I think it's counterproductive
oh okay no this is a good point the very
people you're trying to talk sense into
are the ones you want watching your
videos yeah either way I hope you can
measure the results no they seem to
think it's for real as well this is so
strange
hmm
okay DNC zombie
okay this person already doesn't like me
okay
oh look at this thanks for letting us
know I like the new guy unsubscribed
like like clearly that's someone who
thinks this is something we can really
do it's completely nuts so anyway we did
that so we got that
um oh I did get I got a ton a ton a ton
of different like anti-max mask and
anti-vaxx freakout freakouts and stuff
like that
um we can look at some of those
oh hold on let me say thank you to a few
other people thanks to Douglas Hawley
for signing up on my website Michelle
Dobbs just signed up with the coupon
code Obama Obama
and
wojak low week lowek just signed up with
the coupon code Obama oh
that puts us at 46. okay let me get to
some super chats because since they're
not showing up on screen today due to a
technical problem I have been unable to
put them up uh Mario via says Satsuma
very important on the book The sellout
oh that's interesting
sellout satsumo
oh I'm going to look into that that
looks interesting
so a cultural aspect to it
uh and let me see were there any other
super chats I know that because they're
not on the screen a lot of people think
they're not working they actually are
um
oh thanks to Osama fathi for the 10 euro
Super Chat appreciate that okay a couple
people are asking about whether Whitney
called in during my break she did
so I'm glad to do some Whitney
voicemails or we can do anti-mask stuff
first what do people prefer
I will do both yeah I know everybody
relax we're going to do both just a
question of which one we do first
couple voicemails okay that's fine oh
and and also over on Twitch I want to
say thank you to
um hold on a second do you grock
6lj and Skittle stew putting us at 49 if
we get to a hundred I will commit to
another stream tomorrow and we'll keep
going we'll keep going all the way
through uh through New Year's Eve let's
listen to a couple of these let's listen
to a couple of these Whitney
voicemails so we want Whitney and unread
would you believe that there are
currently
35 unread Whitney voicemails let's
listen to a couple
um not really feeling in the Christmas
spirit so I figured I'd tell you
um I was doing some thinking actually
about like vaccines and stuff
um
so I'm like really appreciating people
who stand up and vouch for vaccines
because it's like you know what if
everybody was to get on the same side as
like you know we don't need vaccines and
a lot of really deep stuff there by the
way how or the calzones
um
let's see what else we've got
you know what really really infuriates
me about racist people
is that I could come up with an
extremely good argument have facts to
back it up have good vocabulary have
everything be assertive
be right and all these racist people
have to say is
wow
because they've been so amped up by
their race card that they think all they
have to say is wow because they know
that other people just want their side
of the argument to be right even though
they're wrong
man I don't know what she's talking
about
all right anyways the reason the reason
why I was talking to you
to you thank you there was a girl when I
was like 13 who like went around telling
everybody that I was raped okay uh well
we're gonna move on we're gonna move on
here's a different one this was all
through my vacation Whitney was just
calling in okay so I just heard on the
news that there was a doctor and he was
like going into immense detail about the
Omicron virus and then it started in
South Africa and he had to make a point
of being like you know with this kind of
a thing like we want to make sure to
deal with it correctly and not blame
the person the place the country
where it started man it was just endless
voicemails the entire vacation
so just uh going based off is like my
history lesson of what I've researched
so there was Richard III's family and
then like fast forward to the Holocaust
um but after the English people tore
down the monarchy
um or at least try to and like kind of
somewhat ruined their rules and I got
slaves from Africa
hmm
um let's do like one or two more it's
kind of bumming me out
is really wacky in general especially
like in context and society and how it's
being used and how it's been used in the
past
um it's been highly abusive like if you
look up therapy and you look up the
history of therapy they're abusers man
there's a lot going on here
uh
uh let's try one more
so did you know that um red hair
originated in the Middle East where
there's like Muslim
um religious prominent over there and
it's not an Egypt in Egypt the so you've
changed to Christianity because they
went up to Greece and then we wrote the
Bible for themselves when they're
included man all right we're gonna get
away from that
maybe just maybe just one more
gay people getting married like
consensually
but when it's like oh well they're gonna
marry the men and come out of the closet
as gay being like oh we're just using
the men for money and basically
neutering their brains with freaking
medication because they have a mental
illness
then and also mutilating children
none of what she's saying is true
so that's that
[Applause]
um
let me see if I have anything else
from you guys
uh
I did get a few from Jimmy from Philly
while I was gone
uh
uh let's see what he had to say
it's pretty wacky stuff
this is silly
so I just watched your best new caller
and history segment and he sounds like
my kind of guy you know Jimmy actually
got arrested during my vacation this is
not a joke guys
this is not a joke and he sort of like
wants me to talk about it but there's
there's lawyers involved
um it's it's actually pretty bad so I'm
not going to talk about it right now
anyway
uh yeah David Jimmy from Philly what
so um are you aware that Biden has some
uh
questionable advances towards his
daughter in the shower he might even
Banger David that's absolutely untrue
and completely disgusting and deplorable
uh he continued calling in
well let me ask you do you sometimes
feel like you're just letting it hang
out oh this is Jimmy now calling with
some kind of
like voice to text thing I don't even
get what this is then he called in again
I just got my second Community strike
from uh the [ __ ] at YouTube
for for talking about the rigged
election you know the one where the most
popular president ever won that [ __ ]
potato in Chief yeah yeah the one where
he got 81 million votes yeah well what
dumbass believes that so Jimmy having a
bad day there and then he made one more
call
David Jimmy from Philly White so I was
recently arrested
okay so now he's talking about it
so if you want to talk about let me know
do it on Discord or side think I'm I
don't I don't know if I'm working
Wednesday I think that's the day you do
that [ __ ]
isn't it Wednesday
but it's it's it's it's
a fantastic story it's like it's like
unbelievable what this girl did I think
Jimmy's accused of actually assaulting a
woman
you know and I got of course said the
one of the best criminal attorneys in
Philadelphia but but let me know let me
know see ya
I don't see myself doing that but
um I mean since he called in
I've got the information here he
actually sent me I don't know why but he
sent me his court documents
um let me see exactly
what the arrest was for
um
hold on a second here it's all pretty
unremarkable
um
yeah
um Jimmy from Philly
I'm just gonna say what the allegation
is
officers determined that there was
probable cause to believe that Jimmy
from Philly struck the victim multiple
times and subjected the victim to
unwanted physical contact
Jimmy from Philly shouted at the victim
through her locked bedroom door that he
would break it down and beat her
he then threw multiple
household items at the door
uh he left and then came back with a
rock
and stated he intended to use the rock
to break the victim's window
um yeah
so
the report does not say Jimmy from
Philly it has his actual name but
obviously I'm not going to do that
so Jimmy from Philly very very much in
the court system at this point in time
uh
that's that's it okay so I don't think
we're going to be doing any interview
about that okay a few super chats Lily
says I had one jnj late later Pfizer
which they s called my booster now they
say I'm only vaccinated not boosted how
dangerous is Omicron now all appears to
be lower hospitalization rate but
extremely extremely contagious
Mike says via Super Chat David breaking
news CDC recommends cutting isolation
time from 10 to 5 days Ah that's good if
it's safe obviously
um
other super chats
I guess that's it okay
seems to be all we have from the
standpoint of super chats I want to say
thank you to denya not denya Dawson who
just signed up with the coupon code
obamna Obama putting us at 50. also want
to say thanks to people supporting via
twitch including
sea missile K shreds webtech Amber Resh
was here
Paul Blart poop fart and vaderette
putting us at 56 as I mentioned we've
had a dramatic reduction in members due
to lack of streams some technical issues
and a bunch of different stuff
so if we get to 100 today and we're 56
percent of the way there I will agree to
do a stream tomorrow that will give us
two streams tomorrow because we've got
the town hall tomorrow if we do it
tomorrow I will stream Wednesday if we
do Wednesday I'll stream Thursday and if
we do Thursday I will commit to a New
Year's Eve stream on Friday so a lot of
streaming hopefully to close out the
year and the town hall is at 6 PM
Eastern tomorrow
6 p.m Eastern
and it'll be only on the Pacman live
Channel ferret queen says I did a Super
Chat way back you missed it yeah because
of how this is working today I can only
see back about 10 minutes
and I apologize that there's not much I
can do about that
um
okay
very good all right let's continue
moving on let's do the mask stuff okay
so a lot of different mask elements
first of all here are this was during
the break
anti-maskers waving an American flag
outside the local Applebee's and
Applebee's is a success bro let me get a
flag wave real quick they got kicked out
oh
once again 14 miles away with Applebee's
had no problem they had freedom shirts
lead the funny part is being so
insistent on going to Applebee's that
you go to multiple Applebee's to try to
get in without a mask well let me get
some let me get some some Flex bro
victory
yeah
cheesecake six Applebee's four that's
where we're going next we're going next
bro uh I think there was another
Applebee's mask incident too
[Music]
um
hmm
maybe they don't use the
hmm
oh yeah I think this was the incident in
New York City
[Music]
I'm on my life
all right anyway all this math stuff is
so depressing good question in chat am I
willing to eat a Satsuma Mandarin on
stream if you're just joining us
um I did outline the absolute best
citrus fruit it's called the Satsuma
Mandarin or Satsuma Orange
um if we get to a hundred members not
only will I stream tomorrow before the
town hall I'll eat I have a bunch of
satsumas in the fridge I will I will
show you exactly how easy they are to
peel and uh I can't really show you how
delicious they are but I will have one
on stream tomorrow so we'll add some
fruit to the stream if we get to 100
tomorrow stream plus eating Mandarin
it'll be really good people asking what
kind of a mask I'm wearing right now I'm
wearing a KN 95 at this point I've
upgraded from just cloth to a kn95 not
wearing it Outdoors
just uh indoors as required let's look
at a couple others this is this is now
anti-masker goes shopping these are just
happening all the time all the time
let's take a look
all right so here we go
see that's how you do it
and then you don't sign in
and now I'm gonna walk through here with
my camera this time
hey
you can't push me around like that can
you put a mask you can't push can you
push them up so I'm like I'm asking you
to put a mask on look at this guy look
at this guy oh
my God this is this Australia because
you do not see store employees manhandle
customers in this way here
so I did not know that human rights
covered access to particular businesses
but it's my human rights my human right
guys upon yours good are you we're not
we're not discriminating against you
mate yes
we've asked you to put a mask on
basketball by the way this guy now has
his mask is so far down that like if
either of these guys had covet they're
definitely giving it to each other
standing this close and yelling
go tell the government that why are you
wearing on the train station why are you
wearing on the bus don't you don't wear
it anywhere well you're not coming in
here you've been banned for two years
now you just refused me service yeah we
can and you can start it but I got the
song on video good good who are you good
Kyle yeah good
hey
[Music]
there it is
there's another one yeah you're not
coming out to the store told you that
the other just because of them told you
that the other day yeah you guys are
right this guy this guy's been going to
the same store for a while
hold on a second is it a human right or
is it a legal right this guy doesn't
have the best grasp of jurisdiction and
anything
again it got revived on the 2nd of
December you don't have to come in here
so you guys are [ __ ] up
from the store so go away your Simple
Choice you guys denied me service in
time you've denied me service twice now
it's funny how he says you've denied me
Service as if that's a problem like yeah
the business can deny that's correct the
business has denied you service yes now
and what's next that's it okay well I've
got some legal action to take the gifts
you [ __ ] whatever
okay see you Carl see you mate you're
abusive [ __ ] [ __ ] you're a big boy
you're a big boy you're a big boy you
tried to [ __ ] punch me baby I've been
in many fights so I could have [ __ ]
knocked you out
hey that's what you get at miter 10 guys
man what a depressing depressing series
of events truly
um thank you to Nicholas Spano who just
signed up on my website with the coupon
code Obama Obama you are new member
number 57
also over on Twitch I want to say thanks
to AJ Scorpia fast and Harry and tobes
putting us at 61.
um if we get to 100 we'll have a stream
tomorrow and I will have I will peel a
Satsuma Mandarin for you guys on stream
I don't know why people care about that
but they're delicious and I will do it
also thanks to erroneous new member
number 62 today uh very much appreciate
that all right let's keep going with the
wackiness here here is a woman who
called the cops because she was denied
entry to a store for not wearing a mask
she she called the police okay actually
you actually so you're one of the first
people that I've called 9-1-1 who
actually doesn't seem to understand that
in the end I'm actually the one with the
rights even though it's mandated it's
not actually a law it's based off of an
emergency state of emergency that we are
no longer in so it's really not I mean a
store can say you got to wear shoes or
you got to wear a mask it's not but I'm
not saying they are literally the same
thing but the legal basis for it is
there
[Music]
Sue this gentleman I could and I will
win 9-1-1 doesn't get involved in
lawsuits you know it's funny how many
people think that they would win a
lawsuit
I'll work with Dell big tree I'll work
with Robert Kennedy Jr I'll work with
yeah Robert Kennedy is going to get
involved
his wife Cheryl Hines required people at
their own party to be vaccinated e Hall
um and those are names that you might
not be familiar with but I am and she'll
also call Anthony Hopkins Leo DiCaprio
and that guy Bartman who ruined the
Chicago Cubs shot at a World Series way
back when everybody's gonna help her I
know that everyone who calls
their rights be supported to be able to
shop by being able to breathe in O2 not
CO2 they're all winning their cases
I will wait in my truck here's the thing
what's going to happen is the gentleman
is going to close his door because they
close in four minutes I drove all the
way out here to purchase a couple of
items so what exactly should I do
because I'd like to just walk on in grab
the items
not the owner
doesn't matter if it's the owner
actually they still have a right to
reduce
[Music]
okay so then you could just let the
officer know that I'm leaving and well
then there's no point in sending the
officer imagine she's gone the officer
shows up and goes did you refuse someone
entry yeah okay
I don't want you to
[Music]
you
oh you're going are you going live too
I'm just recording you're recording me
that's fine you are welcome to do your
research to find it in the end
I don't care
yeah it's like the employee is also not
a lawyer it's because I am here to be
purchasing items I'm not here to be
I'm the one who has the right ma'am you
hear them you hear me I'm just doing my
job can you step outside yeah and um
could you make sure that this gentleman
gives me his name as well ma'am just
through the phone can you at least help
me to get his name
if I could have your name too because my
name's Aiden Bearpaw I'm an employee
here at bones and scones good perfect
bones and scones I like that so at least
I have your name because if I wanted to
I could take it further and I won't okay
so she's not gonna take it any further
okay but she has the information now to
be able to do it I'm not here to do that
okay have a lovely day and I was
discriminated again okay for not being
able to stop shop at yourself that's
your narrative okay Wonder beautiful
thank you in fact I'll just go live too
for a second I mean why it seems very
pointless you want to okay
I'm just doing my job and I'm just I
have rules I will get in trouble if I
let you in without a mask we have a lot
of elderly customers you know it's a
it's a county elderly customer it really
doesn't matter yeah
officer could you ask him to step away
from the doors making me feel fine oh
wait a second so the cops show up hold
on is there a second part here
does anybody know where we can find the
second part I actually want to see the
conversation
trying to look to see if there's
anything
oh hold on maybe this gives us the
information here
oh no this one is this even the same
person that doesn't seem to be it
anybody know where we can find this the
part two
because I am not
I don't even know how I would find it
I really want to if the officer is there
I really want to see part two
yeah I'm not seeing it
woman calls the cops bones let me see if
I search Twitter for bones and scones oh
wait oh hold on I can go to tick tock
for that user let's see
I can't even see what that says
oh
Aphrodite okay let's see here
tick tock
oh it's the it's the employee oh okay
hold on hold on hold on
oh here it is oh this is genius
that's that's the that's the ticket
let's see let's see what happened with
the police purchase a couple of items so
what exactly actually purchase a couple
of it
EMS you are welcome to do your research
to find that if I can have your name too
because
I mean if you want to ask we have a lot
of elderly customers
making me feel kind of unsafe with her
okay no maybe there isn't
purchase all right I guess we're not
going to be able to see it
um that's really too bad I was hoping to
see what what was going to happen there
uh here's a woman on a delayed flight
this one isn't even mask this just seems
to be someone kind of losing it tries to
knock on the cockpit door and claims to
work for the airline let's see what this
is about
it
I'm not no
Jessica
that's an FAA violation oh my God this
woman
can you like start the flight please
I mean obviously they're not opening
charging it and I'm just trying to ask
I asked the flexors
what's with the whiny voice man what an
what a level of entitlement
um okay so next we're going to look at
the let's go Brandon guy uh before we
move on I do want to say thanks to Sam
the sleaze bag as well as Andre BMR for
signing up via twitch Prime putting us
at 64.
um as I said before if you're just
joining us we we are back I am back and
we will potentially have every single
day of the week streams leading up to
and including New Year's Eve tomorrow we
have a plan for the Pacman live viewer
Town Hall at 6 PM Eastern if we get to a
hundred
I will do a stream on Twitch and YouTube
and Facebook before the town hall
tomorrow we are almost two-thirds of the
way there you can sign up at
joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code Obama Obama to get a huge discount
you can also pay full price for a year
and I'll send you a free t-shirt if you
want you can sign email info
davidpackman.com you can also use your
Bezos bucks and just grab a twitch
subscription however we get to 100 we
will lock in a stream for tomorrow
and then we will just take it day by day
okay we will take it day by day okay
let's talk about the Jared schmeck thing
this was a viral story over the holiday
weekend Joe and Jill Biden spoke on the
phone with some people and in fact we
should probably even just to like be
thorough I should probably even play
that clip this guy got on the phone with
them
and uh where is it here
hold on a second where did that go
oh here it is this guy got on the phone
with Joe and Jill Biden and said let's
go Brandon and the right Wingers loved
it here it is listen to you Jerry this
is to the kids
I hope you have a wonderful Christmas
yeah I hope you guys have a wonderful
Christmas as well
um
great hey by the way what are you in
Oregon no I think Jill Biden recognizes
what's going on because she has a very
dejected uh uh mood here
where's your home
I think we lost you yeah so it sort of
seems like Jill Biden knows what's going
on okay so this guy Jared schmeck
claimed I'm not a Trumper I don't even
really dislike Biden you know I'm not
some right-wing nut
but then he was on with Stephen Bannon
today and look at what he said he first
of all he's wearing a Maga hat
and tell me this guy's not a Trumper it
I know it was said in a in a joking
manner in a humorous manner but it's a
very serious uh thing and I mean it's
these guys are upset that people are now
annoyed with him for me to like man I
got a chance right now to to voice my
disapproval of of this man and his like
you didn't really voice it because Joe
Biden didn't even know what the hell you
were talking about it's a it was a
wasted opportunity
Administration
and what is it what is that what is that
disability your John Q public what is
that what is that disapproval can you
define that for us
yeah yeah I mean for me let's go Brandon
is and I've said it in other articles I
am a Christian man uh it's for me it's
God first and foremost I don't follow
any one man blindly
um some of the media is run with that
and said I don't support Donald Trump
that's absolutely false Donald Trump is
my president and he should still be
president I said I'm not a Trumper right
now uh the election was 100 stolen
um so not a Trumper wearing make America
great again hat
uh believes the election was stolen by
Joe Biden so I just want to make that
clear yeah
um but uh let's go Brandon is is more
than just F Joe Biden it's actually kind
of not let's go Brandon is it
encompasses the the entirety of our
frustration with
Joe Biden the administration the leftist
mob the council culture the mainstream
media they're the ones who made this the
left not a Trumper he's sick of the
leftist mob yes a thing and we're we're
able as conservatives we're able to find
humor in this
um but there's terrible things going the
funny thing is
like I don't know how many of you guys
have seen videos of Jim Brewer
doing comedy
but like the right can't do comedy and
they don't understand satire
uh and now he's saying well this is a
comedic movement we're using comedy to
get our points across what why not uh
we've got the debacle in Afghanistan I
mean they're not even talking about that
anymore it's crazy to me how quickly
they they forgot that story and no one's
talking about it there's still people
trapped over there
um we've got the supply chain issues
we've got the inflation rates we've got
uh terrible policies on on abortion I'm
a very pro-life person
um and uh absolutely terrible uh
policies on abortion
um and the the Border crisis by the way
this is a real question can someone in
the chat
tell me how abortion law federally has
become more permissive under Biden since
Trump was president
can anyone in the chat tell me that
if anything based on the Texas law
abortion rights have been curtailed
since Joe Biden has become president
they haven't okay okay
yeah right and of course Roe v Wade has
50 years of precedent yes I know very
good point green man yeah this guy's
living in a fantasy world uh the federal
mandates regarding vaccines I mean it
just there's more than I could even say
the only thing I'm wondering is how did
this guy even get on the phone with Joe
Biden like what lie did he have to tell
or who what what was the vetting
I have I I have absolutely no idea I
don't know how on Earth this guy
actually got on the phone with uh with
Joe Biden very very strange stuff okay
um let me continue thanking people Brook
C fish Flem constantly sleepy and John
Oliver have signed up via twitch Prime I
also want to say thank you to Lee Smith
and Danny Thompson
who have signed up on my website
joinpakman.com using the coupon code
Obama
new members 69 and 70. we are almost
there guys it would be a tragedy if we
were to fall short of locking in another
stream tomorrow in particular during
which I will unveil one of my Satsuma
well that's not Satsuma one of my
Satsuma mandarins so let's just do it
let's just do it okay next thing I don't
remember who sent me this this is my new
favorite thing
this is a website in which you can type
in anything like for example here I've
typed in toilet and you get instantly
linked to when Trump said these words so
like theoretically let's say we want to
figure out where where are those
examples of when Trump would talk about
flushing toilets okay you just type in
toilet and look at this this is a this
is a treasure trove
[Music]
but I don't say it because every time I
say it they only talk about that one
because it's sort of gross to talk about
right so I won't I won't talk about the
fact that people have to flush their
toilet 15 times
I will not talk about it I'll only talk
about showers and okay but there is
three things I won't talk about it this
way they can't report they can't report
it so what happens so what happens I
call my people environmental people what
okay so here's another one it just
directly links you to it it's genius
it's common sense so now when you
actually go into a new home and pay a
lot of money you turn on a faucet and
water actually comes out isn't that nice
that was a regulation that was put in by
a lot of people that don't understand
life
because you'll end up using the same
amount of water you just let it run
three times longer
it's crazy and one other thing I did
remember the old light bulb the old
light bulb was so great
and they put it out of business it was
much cheaper and it had much better
light
and you're all good looking people but
you look better under the old light bulb
than that horrible new light bulb right
of course you're a fraction of the cost
didn't last as long but that's okay but
it cost you a fraction
I reinstituted and opened it up so they
can sell both they can sell the new one
if you want it and they can sell the old
one the old one's doing amazing business
amazing business and you know the new
one is considered hazardous waste
when you lose it you're supposed to take
it down to a a dump a specified dump how
many people are going to do that with a
light bulb hey you know we lost this
light bulb Let's Travel he's actually
not mentioning the toilet here
but let's see where he gets to it
uh
miles outside of the city to get rid of
it's hazardous waste so I put the old
bulb back in and you can use the new one
you can use anything I guess all right
well anyway let's see another one
this is the best
uh-oh sinks toilets light bulbs
but sinks
toilets and showers
you don't get any water
they put restrictors on and now they
made them permanent people used to take
them out they put restrictors on try
going and buying a new faucet you turn
it on no water comes out right
we won't talk about toilets but you know
that's true
okay
10 15.
all right let's try so it's fact based
it's fact-based Trump search
um what's another word let's see if we
search for dumps
let's see here
that video is unavailable
interesting knew it and understood it
well our nation's greatest political
professionals were calling to
congratulate me on our victory
then suddenly everything started to
disappear everything started to change
here it is the vote counting abruptly
stopped in multiple states in the middle
of the night a series of massive and
statistically inconceivable vote dumps
overturned the results in state after
state
oh this is just crazy
this is crazy
oh man
here's another one
this is the best website maybe known to
man
or because we lost by a very close
number
the alleged Biden margin of victory in
several States is entirely accounted for
by extraordinarily large midnight vote
dumps you saw them with going up to the
sky
all extremely skewed to Biden like Biden
would get 10 000 votes and Trump would
get three oh my God
this is insane
let's see if there's any others
this is the best way to search for it
you go right to it it's playing games
nobody's ever before this is the first
time Republicans your first time anyone
has fought back
the 2020 election was rigged it was a
scam and the whole world is watching and
they're laughing at our country They're
laughing at us they know who won and we
won by a lot
the pole Watchers were thrown out of
buildings or put it very far away
distances but they were thrown out of
buildings in
numerous of the states uh you have
people that came in to vote
and they were told I'm sorry but you've
already voted we've received your ballot
no I never voted I'm very proud to vote
November very proud
of them we have your ballot
ballot and they would go in and they
would sign a complaint and some people
in some cases they went home and they
they cried they've never seen it seems
that the time codes are not necessarily
exactly right
thousands and thousands of people that
walked in this shows you how arrogant
the Democrats and others were in
take it away and stealing an election
because that's what they've tried to do
is steal it an easy route for me with
everyone's saying oh just focus on 2024
sir all right so yeah maybe it's not uh
that one doesn't seem to go
directly to it
um
this was actually the Classic this was
where we were oh no unavailable that's
too bad
does it play over it no it doesn't okay
that's too bad all right let's try one
more let's try sir combined with
something else
sir combined with what might give us
something interesting
in the meantime I do want to say thank
you oh my goodness speaking of of uh
dumps memberships just dumping in
everywhere ADI Roderick just signed up
on my website Hogan Garcia is a new
member and Tony Johnson all signing up
with the code Obama Obama
putting us at 73 over on Twitch thanks
to Lucan and agaste putting us at 75 we
are almost there we are almost there oh
sir wife
air
let's see
oh this is the one that's genius check
this out and I think it came out of Los
Angeles I think they actually bought it
in Los Angeles which is such a but they
love the job she's doing
and yesterday they had a problem right
you saw that fire on the plane
and I got a call
sir your wife is up in the air there's a
fire on the plane I said don't tell me
that don't tell me oh man that is genius
all right anything else sir wife air is
a good one
what about the one word Trump said
Melania calls him sir
um let me see how I can do that
it was like did you see it first
lady sir let me see if that comes no
that didn't see him
first lady sir
might have been this one
these are the best
they said sir uh Baron he just White
House doctor great doctor Sean
sir Barra just tested positive I said
test it positive for what
for Corona you know it sounds like no
this one's not it it's that one would be
tough to find because I don't remember
the exact context
where it was like she was supposedly
saying something
yeah I don't know
all right let's try it let's try like
one more I don't know why it defaults to
toilet that's weird
um what about sir
disinfectant let's see
no that didn't work
she said sir let's see
that's he said sir
no it's not coming up
hmm
any all right any other ideas people
want me to try
Mr President sir
oh the website seems to have Frozen
Mr President sir
our first lady said sir
nah
this is fact-based guys I have never
seen as an entertaining website as this
sir Melania
nope that's not having that's not
happening
um
oh is are we crashing the website
everybody's doing searches
you have to flush the website let's just
see if we can find flush
flush combined with sir
no that doesn't work maybe toilet and
sir
nope
okay all right I think we're done with
this as entertaining as it is oh very
large Brain yeah that might be a good
one
this is a classic so I won't mention the
name of the show recently and he was
saying that China has total respect for
Donald Trump and for Donald Trump's very
very large
a brain he said Donald
that is a that is a classic
that is a classic oh the best words
let's see
hmm that I'm not seeing maybe if I put
it in quotes ah the quotes
very highly educated I know words I have
the best words I have to but there's no
better word than stupid
right there is none there is none
all right I don't know if it'll find
Obama
that's a good question let's see
now it's probably spelled correctly in
the transcript
would be my guess
stable genius
okay let's see
this is a fascinating website
don't know why it's not working
hmm
only ones that don't like my
conversation are the ones that never
read it but they heard Shifty shift
that's what I call a lie and because of
the fact that he's
he's lying about the president of the
United States and as to what the
President says you know I believe it or
not I watch my words very carefully
there are those that think I'm a very
stable genius yeah okay I watch my words
very very closely extremely stable
it's extremely stable oh yeah when he
mispronounced Motown
yeah here it is That's a classic
we inherit the legacy of Michigan
Patriots who gave their Blood Sweat and
Tears for this beloved Nation
this is the state where Henry Ford
invented the assembly line think of that
it's the place where General Motors
Chrysler and Kellogg
revolutionized entire Industries what a
State Michigan gave us Motown the
Mustang and that's how you pronounced it
correctly
that one was correct
[Music]
um
Yosemite
all right this is going to be the last
one
this is a real classic
it really keeps you waiting in front
we want every American child to have
access to pristine outdoor spaces
when Young Americans experience the
breathtaking beauty of the Grand Canyon
when their eyes widen in amazement As
Old Faithful bursts into the sky
when they gaze upon your semites your
seminites
all right okay we're um we're done with
that
that was a good one that was a very good
one I want to say thank you to Cheryl
Hathaway as well as Tara O'Brien who
just signed up on my website with the
coupon code Obama number 76 and 77 also
thanks to Jeff in Boston doubled bottom
and a gift from Jeff in Boston all on
Twitch putting us at 80. we are getting
closer to the end of today's material we
are going to do a stream tomorrow if we
get to a hundred this is website and
twitch both count both count okay we are
very close let's not fall short of that
goal let's not fall short of that goal
okay let's get to a few other voicemails
because we did get a ton of voicemails
during the break it's actually shocking
how many we got
um
uh Troy York for example
uh I believe his name was Karen's
cousins or something like that
um I can honestly say
um you would have been better off
um basically not having this guy on oh
and you have been better off on
steinwheel casting
um your program
with
um simul the host of the majority
reports
well Sam was awesome man Troy York just
has no idea what's going on
it's it's sort of
sort of disturbing quite frankly like
just no idea whatsoever what's taking
place on this planet
um
all right I'm willing to do like two
more Whitney ones but then we're gonna
we've really gotta pull it
hi David
um this is Whitney I read them YouTube
Sorry watched it I watched the Youtube
video
um did you say she read YouTube where I
was
um public speaking correctly
um I didn't watch all of it just because
I have this like unrational fear of my
own voice
um but what I did do is I did find
somebody who's a really good public
speaker and I know it's like kind of
irrelevant
um to some stuff
um okay and then Whitney also chiming in
again
hi this is Whitney again
and stuff
is
um
just like how crazy therapy is in
general
for somebody to a lot of like
anti-therapy stuff I'm noticing
with Whitney like a crazy crazy amount
uh uh see if I've got anything else
interesting for you guys oh thanks to
Andrew AVR drums for signing up on my
website new member number 81 guys we
might be about to do it
Rich bird nation tyoxyl and but it's my
HIPAA have signed up via twitch Prime
putting us at 84 but it's my HIPAA says
what was the name of the site with the
Trump Clips it is
um fact-based
you go to fact base you go to search and
you go to Donald Trump
um oh interesting you can search other
presidents
oh it's just Biden and Trump okay
all right I got it fair
um
okay very good let's see if we've got a
couple other interesting voicemails
normal ones normal ones as I like to say
um
what do I have here
David sir have you noticed ever since
Trump there's a a debasement in language
for example he would always use the word
cyber not as an adjective but as a noun
and now intelligent people including
yourself
use it as a noun when did I use cyber as
a noun
I don't remember doing that at all
maybe I did but I don't know
um Eric from Mass continued calling in
through my vacation hey David I got a
it's uh Eric for math I got some uh
interesting scientific evidence for you
uh I think you're gonna enjoy it
everyone will enjoy it on your uh site
the root cause of cancer is oxygen
deficiency which creates an Pacific
state in the human body okay we're
moving on those statements have not been
evaluated
um
yeah
let's see what else we've got here
man just so actually Eric Eric called in
constantly hey David Eric from Mass the
uh Lancet report would you love the
Lansing people just came out and
admitted it's uh a pandemic of the
vaccinated
pandemic of the vaccinated that is not
what they said he's continuing
hey David it's Eric from Mass uh the FDA
documents have been released and it
ain't good
um I'm sure you'll cover it up or ignore
it I won't talk I can never find any of
the supposed documents he refers to ever
hey David it's better for Mass you check
the FDA website yet let's cover up is
worse than the crime you uh probably
scrambling to think what what am I going
to say oh
um I'm going to pretend like I didn't
know I'm going to pretend like
um uh I I was just saying they these
were guidelines oh my God what is he
talking about hey David Eric from Mass
it's uh worse than it looks 150 000 uh
adverse reactions in the first three
months and you [ __ ] covered this up I
hope they arrest you me why would I get
arrested everything you're saying is a
lie
hey David Eric from Mass uh Bill Gates
uh is being tried for murder due to the
vaccines over in India you can look it
up the file documents are there the
Court's transcripts what
Billy let's just listen Bill Gates tried
for murder India
uh no that's a false claim it's also a
year and a half old story wow wow what
is uh what on Earth is this guy talking
about
I just don't even know the origins of
these stories
hmm
Eric Christie has just signed up on my
website and is new member number 85.
also Leon Avalon and Justin Andrew
Watson signing up via twitch guys we are
87 of the way there actually that would
be a good search to do
oranges nope it's not there
maybe they have it
ah yeah that's funny see they the
website really should track it the way
Trump says it you know
that would make a lot more sense I think
let's see if we can get this to play
we're just finished
it's totally finished no collusion no
obstruction I hope they now go and take
a look at the oranges or the oranges of
the uh uh investigation the beginnings
of that
man it is it is remarkable how
desensitized we were to this Insanity
before because in watching it now it
seems so much crazier
so much crazier it because it was
happening daily I think that that was
why
we were sort of desensitized to it
um okay a couple other uh
a couple other voicemails I do have a
lot of stuff here here's a foreign
caller let's take a listen
hey David uh well so I only uh started
watching it a few months ago and I was
wondering how is it even possible for
Democrats to win the house without uh
election reform and uh
can't the Republican
redistrict themselves
through a health majority oh my God
hey David I love the show uh I was just
wondering that uh
okay then they call back again
hi David uh I was just wondering uh is
it
even possible for Democrats to win over
the house uh the considering
redistricting
and uh
okay then called back again
hey David uh I was just wondering is
this even possible for Democrats to win
uh the house of represent man it's the
same question every voicemail that's
unusual you don't
you don't usually see that
um
interesting interesting
let me see if I've got anything else
interesting for you guys
no I think I think that's probably good
on voicemails
okay all right I see enough people
asking about the five-day quarantine let
me see about that so CDC 10 day to five
day
isolation
CDC changes isolation guidelines okay
let's take a look at that I actually
don't know if this is based on science
or if this is based on economics let's
take a look here CDC cuts
oh my God
all right
let's try a different one
let's look at the actual CDC okay better
that's weird I do pay for the New York
Times I guess I'm not logged in in that
browser no but it said my free articles
I don't know okay CDC updates and
shortens recommended isolation and
quarantine period This is actually a big
deal given hold on is this even on the
screen properly yeah it is given what we
currently know about covid-19 and the
Omicron variant CDC is shortening the
recommended time for isolation from 10
days for people with covid to five days
if asymptomatic
followed by five days of wearing a mask
when around others
the changes motivated by science
demonstrating the majority of
transmission occurs early generally in
the one to two days prior to the onset
of symptoms and the two to three days
after
therefore people who test positive
should isolate for five days if
asymptomatic they can leave isolation if
they can continue to mask for five more
days to minimize infecting others
CDC is updating recommended quarantine
period for those exposed this is
actually relevant to my run-in with
Omicron which I will detail later uh
later in the week CDC is okay for people
who are unvaccinated or more than six
months out from the second dose or two
months after jnj and not boosted
CDC recommends five days of quarantine
followed by strict Mass use
if a five-day quarantine is not feasible
it is imperative that an exposed person
wear a well-fitting mask at all times
for 10 days
individuals who have received their
booster do not need to quarantine it
following an exposure oh but should wear
a mask for 10 days after the exposure
for all those exposed the best practice
includes a test five days after if
symptoms occur individuals should
immediately quarantine
until a negative test confirms symptoms
are not attributable to covid this so
the science of this seems I don't want
to say it's shaky I want to say that
it's
cloudy
and this to me seems more economic when
you look at what's been happening in
healthcare facilities and to Airlines as
a result of people
being off for 10 days
this smells to me of being at least as
economic as it is health related you
guys tell me if you agree or disagree
um
data from South Africa and UK
demonstrate vaccine Effectiveness
against infection for two doses is
approximately 35 percent
the booster restores Effectiveness to 75
percent
okay
well that's the big news
shortened quarantine period shortened
quarantine period
uh
did Airlines request this I know Health
Care Facilities did I don't know if
Airlines also did
I want to say thanks to M slez or Ms Les
as well as micro Kimmy and Paco Taco for
the twitch Prime subscriptions
um
also a big thank you oh no I guess
that's it
okay uh all right let me remind
everybody what we've got coming up over
the next couple of weeks I actually have
a few few announcements to make first of
all tomorrow
oh wait a second where is my
God where did that I don't know where
this stuff is
wait websites
Pac-Man Live YouTube
Pac-Man live here it is
okay
tomorrow is the rescheduled viewer Town
Hall
we were going to do this on December
14th
we are doing it tomorrow because I had
technical issues and I had bandwidth
issues and I had all sorts of different
things when I was traveling so the town
hall is tomorrow it's only going to
stream on Pac-Man Live so I know there
are people tomorrow who are going to go
on the regular channel and say where's
the town hall there are people who are
going to be on Twitch saying where's the
town hall
the town hall will only be on the new
YouTube channel Pacman live 6 PM Eastern
3 P.M Pacific if we get to a hundred
guys we're almost there
it would be a really embarrassing if we
don't get to a hundred if we get to 100
I will also do a stream at four or five
eastern an hour or two on all of the
platforms leading up to the town hall
and today I announced the best citrus
fruit that exists
which is the Satsuma Mandarin I will
also unbox one on tomorrow's stream some
people call it peeling it I call it
unboxing it okay so that's if we get to
a hundred and by God I really hope that
we do it next week January 6th
Donald Trump is going to be doing a
press conference from miralago
on the one year anniversary of the Trump
riots we will be covering that live
that's next week January 6th
and then in addition to that this is By
Request you guys have asked for this on
Tuesday January 11th we are doing the
next the next and the first of the 2022
year
David Pacman showed chess tournament it
is going to be uh explosive it is going
to be explosive and let me see actually
if I have a link set up yet
uh
uh not yet okay I'll give you more
information about that when we get
closer but
um that's going to be really great
everybody's invited it's friendly it's
it's it's going to be absolutely great
I'm gonna see if I can get some uh well
we should see we should see if Ben
Feingold is willing to play we should
see if Levy Rosman wants to play um we
we should get some people involved I'm
actually going to make a note to reach
out to some big chess people tomorrow uh
chess tournament
invites and we'll see if we can get some
major people playing I think that that
would be absolutely fantastic I think it
would be great I want to say thank you
to El Fidel Trump and straight man ha
for contributing via twitch Prime we're
at 92 92 maybe Steven Kenneth Destiny
benel II will play that would be great
but guys I don't know if we're gonna
make it because I'm basically done with
everything I had for today
and we're still eight short of locking
in a stream for tomorrow let's just do
it that's my advice I don't I
it would not be good
if we got so close and failed maybe
Magnus will play yeah that's not a bad
idea
would I be willing to participate in the
chess tournament while in a hot tub
probably not probably not oh by the way
people asking for my take on the use of
slurs I'm against it I don't use slurs
um and I know that a lot of this relates
to the Hassan thing I've already said
I don't use or I try to avoid using any
terms that pejoratively group people by
race I just don't like the terms I don't
think it's a productive term I don't
think it's useful
and that's what it is and I know people
are saying well it's not really about
race anymore or what
come on guys come on let's find ways to
express ourselves including frustration
including
anger or whatever
with words that are not pejorative
race-based groupings that's it guys that
is it
I do want to say thank you
to Sandra or Sandra Bryan who just
signed up on my website with the coupon
code
and I also want to say thanks to Xeno
The Stranger for gifting 10
subscriptions via twitch which locks in
tomorrow's stream oh also thanks to
Lindsay Backstrom who just signed up at
joinpakman.com very very important and
new member number
104. so with that we have locked in a
stream tomorrow I'm ready to stream all
the way through up to and including New
Year's Eve so live stream tomorrow
between 4 and 5 Eastern subsequent Town
Hall at 6 PM Eastern and we'll try to go
for another stream on Wednesday all
right everybody thanks for joining me
great to be back and we'll see everybody
tomorrow
foreign